In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxanian for June 7th, on which we commemorate St. Panaïs, Basia.
Born in 1801 into a distinguished family in Kifalonia, St. Panaïs showed from childhood
a lively intelligence and a great love for reading the holy books.
When his father's death, he had to take over the care of his mother and sister and began
to exercise the function of schoolmaster despite his youth.
But he resigned very soon in order not to have to make a compromise between his faith and
his patriotic feelings under the pressure from the British occupiers and carried on his
profession for some time in private until the day when he decided to break off all links
with the world and abandoning his family and his career became a monk in the Blacerné
monastery at the island of Theos.
At his mother's insistence, he returned to Luxury without ever renouncing the ascetic
way of life that he followed all his life, whatever the circumstances.
He was ordained priest at the age of thirty-five and devoted himself entirely from then on
to the service of the church by the almost daily celebration of the divine liturgy and preaching,
and especially by the example of his evangelical virtues.
He stood in church like a stone pillar, and when he came out it was to give alms, visit
the poor, or bring lost souls back to the fold.
He always refused to be appointed to a parish in order to avoid material worries and the
pressures from the occupiers, and settled in the tiny monastery of Saint Speedhon, when
for fifty years he shed a broad on all the people of Caffalonia, the treasures that he kept
hidden in his heart.
Among the examples of St. Yerasimos and St. Anthemos the Blind, Papabasia taught the people
and shed the grace of God among them, without ever abandoning his hermitage.
He also went to celebrate in the chapel's spread all over the countryside around Luxury,
where as soon as they learned of his presence, the faithful would gather in crowds.
He had sold his family possessions and given all his resources to the indigent, whom he
looked on as his sons.
When he went into a town, he was always followed by a swarm of poor women, to whom he gave
all he had, to the point even of depriving himself of food.
As the second St. Nicholas, he knew which family was in special need and intervened to support
it, or give it hope in God.
His charity was, moreover, mingled with audacity, and he often went into a shop, opened the till
and took out what he thought necessary for his arms giving.
One day a baker refused to give him what he asked, and his dough stopped rising.
St. Banayis had acquired the gifts of insight and prophecy, which he exercised for the reform
of souls.
To those who were soon to die, a brutish death, he recommended that they go to confession,
or he warned, with veiled words, those who were about to commit some grave sin.
Once on a rainy night, meeting a man whom he knew was preparing to commit sin, he cried
out to him, sin, sin, go back home.
At another time, a mother who had just lost her two sons in succession was seized with
depression and reiled against God.
The holy priest hurried to her house, and when she refused to open to him, reviling him,
he opened the door with the sign of the cross.
Going into the living room where he found pictures of the two dead men, the portraits
came to life, and taking out pistols, killed each other.
St. Banayis then revealed to the mother that they, having fallen in love with the same woman,
it was thus that they would have perished if God would not have intervened to avoid a
greater evil.
On yet another occasion he went into a house where the pot was bubbling away, waiting for
guests, and he overturned it because a poor man had come to them, and they had sent him
away without giving him anything.
But these abundant gifts of God were not given to Papabhasia without his being tormented
by a thorn in the flesh.
About ten years after his ordination, he began to be troubled by a nervous illness that made
him lose control of himself.
He cried out, shaving off his beard and hair, and throwing out of doors any object that came
to hand.
When he came to himself after six months, he attributed the illness to his being a sinner.
After this, such crises were repeated every two or three years, and in the last years of
his life, the illness attacked him every year.
In the end he was bedridden for the last five years.
He was not, however, deprived of the gifts of prophecy and the consolation of souls, and
the people did not abate any of their affection and devotion for him.
On the contrary, all who were afflicted or found themselves in difficulty knew that the
door of his room was always open, and the holy priest never stopped being the loadstone
and center of the church with a whole of Kifalonia.
He had acquired such authority that he intervened often energetically to correct injustice, or
reprimand those responsible for immoral acts, and was always listened to as the voice of God.
After having endured his long and humiliating illness, that some thought to be a sort of
folly in Christ, as a cross with resignation and thanksgiving, St. Panagis fell asleep in
the Lord on the 7th of June 1888.
For two days and nights the faithful came to venerate his body, and his commemoration has
never ceased to grow spontaneously, not only in Kifalonia, but in the whole of Greece, especially
at the time of the finding of his relics in 1976.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.